Brouhaha de cour d'école
en écho
...
Musique douce grave
-Si je devais
retourner à l'école,
je m'y opposerais
de toutes mes forces.
Mon parcours
a été biaisé.
Pendant ma scolarité,
de nombreuses incompréhensions
ont fortement contribué
à mon décrochage.
Aujourd'hui, j'assimile cette époque
à des expériences épineuses,
particulièrement dans mon rapport
avec les autres.
Je ne supportais pas
le bruit.
La communication avec mes camarades
était difficile.
Pour moi, impossible
de faire du par coeur
ou de poser des équations
sans leur donner du sens.
Comportement atypique,
attitude taciturne :
je passais pour inadapté,
retardé,
voire déficient.
Au fil de ces années,
mon désir d'apprendre
au sein de cet environnement
s'est dissipé.
Pour mes enseignants
et de mes camarades, les signes
d'un haut quotient intellectuel
étaient cachés.
Pourtant, le diagnostic
avait bien été posé.
Le monde devenait brutal,
pour moi,
semant le doute
sur mes capacités.
Musique douce
*-C'est important,
savoir lire et écrire ?
*-Oui.
*-On peut faire quoi,
quand on sait lire ?
*-Raconter des histoires
aux enfants.
*Rires
*- La plupart des enfants,
quand ils sont
d'origine socio-économique modeste,
même s'ils sont précoces,
à l'âge de cinq ans,
échouent,
dans plus de 50 % des cas.
Ce sont des enfants
voués à l'échec.
Si un enfant intelligent s'ennuie
en classe, il peut devenir instable.
D'autres s'endorment.
Ce sont des enfants qui s'ennuyaient
et qui avaient besoin
qu'on leur propose, à leur rythme,
des activités qui les amusent
et qui les alimentent
intellectuellement.
-En France,
ce sujet du haut potentiel
a beaucoup de mal à percer.
En fait,
à la suite de mai 68,
on a considéré que
s'intéresser aux enfants
qui seraient les plus intelligents,
c'était faire
une forme d'élitisme.
-Jean-Charles Terrassier,
psychologue pionnier, en France,
dans le haut potentiel,
met en place un dispositif
d'intégration
à l'attention
de ces enfants.
Selon les académies,
ils représentent
1 élève sur 20,
soit 1 à 2 élèves
par classe.
Dans un quartier populaire
de Nice,
une classe spécifique
voit le jour, en 1987.
Une première
prise de conscience.
C'est seulement 20 ans plus tard
que le dispositif d'intégration
des élèves à haut potentiel
se développe sous sa forme actuelle.
A cette époque,
j'achevais ma scolarité.
Mon envie de découvrir la situation
de ces élèves, aujourd'hui,
et les échecs rencontrés
au cours de ces années,
m'ont longtemps interrogé.
L'encadrement proposé m'aurait-il
permis d'envisager autrement
mon histoire douloureuse
avec le système scolaire ?
Musique intrigante
-L'égalité des chances
n'est pas essayer
de faire entrer
tout le monde dans le moule.
C'est aussi respecter
le développement.
L'intelligence ne se mesure pas
comme la température.
C'est pas une mesure
qui est sûre.
Il n'y a pas de consensus
pour les nommer.
On entend "précoce",
"surdoué"...
Depuis quelques années, c'est plus
"haut potentiel intellectuel"
qui est privilégié.
-Moi, ce que j'observe,
c'est qu'il y a,
d'un côté,
les compétences intellectuelles,
et de l'autre,
la souffrance psychique.
Le haut potentiel ne génère pas
de souffrance,
parce que le haut potentiel
ne parle que d'intelligence,
et l'intelligence
ne génère pas d'anxiété.
-Je dérangeais, en fait,
mes camarades,
parce que
je m'ennuyais, en fait.
-Je suis pas super intelligent,
je suis pas le 1er de ma classe,
j'ai juste la moyenne
de ma classe.
-Il y a des enfants précoces qui ont
de très mauvaises notes.
Il y a des enfants précoces
qui ont de très bonnes notes.
Mais moi, il faut que je travaille
pour les avoir.
-Pour beaucoup,
"précocité" égale
"très bon élève".
Et c'est parfois le cas,
mais c'est pas toujours le cas.
Musique pop
-J'ai grandi
dans les années 1990,
dans une banlieue
de région parisienne.
C'est à cette époque
que j'ai développé mon imaginaire.
Très vite,
je me suis rendu compte
de la nécessité
de me fondre dans le moule,
en ayant des centres d'intérêt
communs avec mes camarades.
Sauf que se déguiser
est comme mettre un masque :
mon attitude taciturne
me trahit : je m'isole
de plus en plus
et je me fais oublier.
De nombreuses désillusions
sont apparues,
laissant place à un grand sentiment
d'échec et d'isolement.
Musique pop
...
C'est ainsi que cette période
s'est déroulée.
Parfois,
j'entends encore ces voix
qui résonnaient,
le dimanche midi.
-Qu'est-ce qu'il a encore fait ?
Ca sera pas
toujours comme ça !
-Y en a marre !
Fais des efforts !
-Qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire de lui ?
-T'exagères !
-Un sentiment d'incompréhension,
d'injustice,
me poussait à l'abandon,
au désinvestissement
de l'apprentissage.
Je collais à l'image
qu'on se faisait de moi,
en rendant
des copies blanches.
Malgré les apparences,
quand j'avais 10 ans,
j'écoutais des émissions politiques
à la radio toute la nuit.
Je suivais les élections
et les films
de campagnes électorales.
Quand mes camarades
regardaient des dessins animés,
je lisais Libération, L'Equipe,
Mozart, Beethov, Vivaldi...
J'étais incollable
sur les compositeurs
de musique classique.
-Certains enfants vont tomber
dans une forme
de conformisme.
J'ai des garçons
à haut potentiel
qui s'imposent d'apprendre par coeur
des équipes de foot,
car un garçon en primaire
qui ne s'intéresse pas au foot,
c'est pas un garçon.
-Le DIEHP : Dispositif d'intégration
des élèves à haut potentiel.
Ils se retrouvent
dans des classes ordinaires,
pas regroupés
dans une classe particulière.
Pour faire partir du dispositif,
il faut avoir fait le test.
-Il y a un incontournable :
c'est la passation
d'une épreuve d'intelligence
de Wechsler.
C'est une épreuve
qui est internationale,
qui est reconnue
dans tous les pays.
On explore divers domaines
de l'intelligence :
compréhension verbale,
raisonnement visio-spatial,
raisonnement fluide,
logique mathématique,
mémoire de travail
et vitesse de traitement.
-Il faut avoir une moyenne
de 130 au test WISC.
Ca, c'est une condition nécessaire,
mais pas suffisante.
Pour être admis dans le dispositif,
il faut avoir eu des soucis
parfois avec des enseignants,
des camarades, avoir été harcelé.
On reçoit des profils
très variés,
mais ils ont tous eu
ce point commun :
une histoire
un petit peu douloureuse
avec l'école,
ou primaire.
-C'est par le versant
des difficultés que l'école,
l'Education nationale,
on est arrivés
à aborder le sujet.
Le revers de la médaille,
c'est qu'à partir des années 1990,
il y a eu
beaucoup de publications,
plus ou moins
scientifiquement fondées,
mais mettant l'accent
sur les difficultés.
Au point que, récemment,
on a pu accuser
tout ce qui avait été publié
de pathologiser
le haut potentiel,
d'oublier qu'il y a
des personnes à haut potentiel
qui vont très bien.
-Ca a sorti de l'ombre
les cancres, en fait.
De réenvisager les enfants
avec un bonnet d'âne
au fond de la classe
comme des enfants plus valeureux
cachant des merveilles.
-Oui, certaines personnes
à haut potentiel
vont très bien,
et, par contre,
d'autres ont des difficultés
et il faut les accompagner.
Musique douce
-CM1, c'est...
C'était un peu...
Je compare un peu
à "Un jour sans fin".
Niveau scolaire,
ça allait,
mais je m'ennuyais
un petit peu, en classe.
Parfois,
je me faisais des amis,
mais il y a eu
quelques histoires,
"Je veux plus être ton ami",
"Je veux redevenir ton ami".
Je me suis dit :
"C'est pas possible,
"on est dans une...
C'est un film, c'est...
"c'est une pièce de théâtre,
"c'est pas possible,
c'est une comédie."
-Oui.
-"C'est... C'est...
"C'est pas possible que ça fasse..."
Y a eu des moments
où c'était un peu comme ça
dans ma tête.
Musique douce
...
-En fait, ça commence
par la maternelle
qui s'est pas bien passée,
pour Césaire.
Beaucoup de difficultés
dans ses rapports
avec ses camarades,
avec ses institutrices.
-On était embêtés, quand même.
Il commençait à être malheureux.
Il revenait, il disait : "J'ai passé
une journée..." Comment ?
"Pourrie" ?
"J'ai passé une horrible journée".
-Ah, oui.
-Donc, bon...
On peut essayer de le travailler,
mais à un moment,
il y a quelque chose qui va pas.
-Mh.
-Dans ce cas, souvent,
le regard sur les parents
est un peu suspicieux.
On imagine que... Enfin, moi,
c'est ce que je ressentais.
Que les parents
ne poussent pas leur enfant
à suivre, à écouter.
Moi, on m'a plusieurs fois dit :
"Laissez-le grandir."
-Oui, on sait qu'il est...
qu'il se stresse
quand il a pas le temps,
quand il pense
qu'il a pas assez
préparé quelque chose...
Mais bon, ça, on...
on travaille, quoi,
et on lui dit.
On lui dit que
c'est pas très important.
Mais pour revenir...
Y avait un isolement, quand même,
avant le DIEHP.
-Donc, rien,
jusqu'à cette fameuse rencontre,
en CE2,
où il a été détecté.
-En 6e,
pour me réorienter,
on me fait passer
des tests psychométriques.
On s'aperçoit
que mon quotient intellectuel
est de 135.
Je garderai toujours
en mémoire
la confusion créée
par ces résultats,
pour moi comme
pour la psychologue,
qui ne comprenait pas le décalage
avec les remarques des professeurs.
Mais c'était trop tard.
J'avais beau avoir surinvesti
le domaine de la pensée,
j'étais en proie au doute.
J'ai développé, enfant,
des difficultés relationnelles,
organisationnelles.
Les attitudes qui en découlaient
me faisaient craindre
le jugement des autres,
renforçant mes incertitudes.
Brouhaha des enfants
...
-Jeune psychologue,
je vais chercher,
à la salle d'attente, l'enfant.
Il était amimique,
il exprimait très peu.
Il avait toujours
la bouche ouverte.
Ma première impression, c'était :
"Ca fait pas très malin."
Il venait,
difficultés à l'école et...
"Ouh là là !
Celui-là, il a pas l'air..."
En moi-même :
"Il n'a pas l'air d'être très futé."
Dans l'entretien,
c'était quelqu'un de très inhibé,
qui parlait pas beaucoup.
Je dis : "Bon, on va quand même
passer un test."
Musique douce
Musique intrigante
Voix indistinctes en écho
...
En fait, le gars, il a fait
plus de 120 de QI.
Ca m'a fait réfléchir,
parce que je crois qu'il faut
être très prudent,
parce que j'entends parfois
des gens qui disent :
"Je vois tout de suite
si vous êtes HPI."
Ils ont l'impression
qu'ils sont une espèce de devin.
Ils oublient, et c'est quelque chose
que j'ai appris,
c'est que l'être humain
n'est pas très bon observateur.
-C'est pas magique,
c'est vraiment au cas par cas.
Donc, il faut avoir
une démarche
très déontologique,
dans l'administration des tests,
qui, quand même,
ont été créés pour débusquer
des précisions
sur les difficultés,
les entraves cognitives,
les déficiences des élèves,
au départ.
Wechsler, etc., ils n'ont
pas du tout créé des tests
pour alimenter
le fantasme narcissique
de parents qui seraient en quête
d'un enfant surdoué,
ou celui de psys
peu scrupuleux,
qui viendraient s'enrichir
sur le dos d'un fantasme.
Brouhaha de cour
de récréation
-Sur la socialisation des enfants,
on a une salle,
qu'on appelle la "salle du DIEHP",
qui est vraiment le refuge.
-C'est bien d'avoir une relation
un peu de confiance
à l'intérieur du collège.
J'ai le droit d'accéder
à une salle du DIEHP.
Brouhaha
-Quand je suis énervé
ou que je me sens pas bien,
je peux aller au DIEHP.
Il respire profondément.
Il murmure.
Je pouvais parler, je...
Je pouvais m'exprimer
et, du coup, me calmer
et revenir en cours
un peu plus tard,
pour relâcher la pression.
-Ils peuvent y aller
quand ils veulent,
pendant la récréation,
le midi,
mais même si, en cours,
ils éprouvent le besoin de sortir,
parce que, émotionnellement,
c'est compliqué ou...
Ils peuvent aller là.
C'est un peu
la salle où...
ils retrouvent
un assistant d'éducation,
mais ils se retrouvent
entre eux, aussi.
Propos indistincts
-Alors on va faire
un petit pacte.
-Ben... Non,
je crois que ça va.
-Quand je suis arrivé,
j'avais quand même
une meilleure idée
des problématiques :
soit des élèves
très, très insolents,
ou multi-exclus,
qui venaient très souvent
dans la salle,
ou des élèves qui seraient
assez discrets,
voire harcelés.
Il respire lourdement.
Oui, c'est Adrien.
*-Oui ?
-C'était pour te dire :
les Pavlova, ils ont cours
le jeudi aprèm, de 14h à 18h.
Brouhaha
En fait, ce qui est paradoxal,
c'est de faire en sorte
qu'ils soient
le moins ici possible.
Donc, quand ils viennent
en traînant des pieds,
alors que ça a sonné
depuis 1 minute,
en disant
"J'ai pas envie d'y aller",
il faut essayer de voir
que ce cas-là
soit pas non plus...
récurrent.
Ca, c'est un des problèmes.
Un des autres soucis,
c'est parfois
la gestion émotionnelle.
Il y a des élèves qui explosent,
un peu comme
des petites bombes
à retardement.
-A peine la sonnerie retentie,
c'est déjà la fin de la récré.
Les groupes d'élèves
se forment dans les couloirs.
Pourvu que la classe
soit déjà ouverte.
Musique mélancolique
Chahut d'enfants
...
Saisis par le brouhaha
qui augmente,
on ne peut plus reculer,
maintenant.
Il n'y a pas le choix.
Rester calme.
Surtout rester calme.
...
-C'est compliqué,
la frontière
entre ce qu'on peut accepter
et ce qu'on ne peut pas.
Ils ont une caractéristique
qui peut engendrer
plus facilement des crises,
et donc jusqu'où on...
-Mais pourquoi
ça engendrerait
des crises ?
-On a des gamins
souvent anxieux.
Il y a une gamine
qui fabrique
des bracelets.
Les collègues l'autorisent
à faire,
mais à condition
qu'elle suive le cours.
Bien sûr,
il y a toujours la condition.
Elle fait pas son truc
et puis rien d'autre.
Elle a le droit
de faire ses bracelets,
parce que justement,
ça aide probablement
à ce qu'elle puisse se concentrer.
J'ai regardé son bulletin de notes,
car je la suis en tutorat,
et elle a 18 de moyenne,
mais elle fait ses bracelets.
-Oui.
-En fait, ça la pénalise pas.
Elle a vraiment cette capacité
à tout retenir hyper rapidement.
Je pense qu'on peut accepter ça.
-Oui.
-On a un autre élève
qui fait du Rubik's Cube.
-Allez,
toujours la même consigne :
vous m'inventez une petite phrase
contenant une assonance en I.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a, Alice ?
Propos indistincts
Musique intrigante
...
-William et son frère Arthur.
William a 14 ans,
Arthur, 11.
A l'école primaire,
William était timide
et parfois bagarreur.
Son attitude inquiète à l'école,
comme au sein de sa famille.
Parents et enseignants pressentent
un parcours très chaotique.
Un ultime incident
a amené son entourage
à trouver une solution.
...
-Je ne sais plus
de quoi c'est parti.
On s'est bagarrés
avec un élève.
Il y avait deux animateurs
pour me retenir
dans ce bureau,
et en fait, à un moment donné,
j'ai réussi à m'évader,
à m'enfuir.
De là,
je voulais absolument me...
"me venger" du...
de la personne
en question.
Au final, il a fallu
trois adultes pour me maîtriser.
-On avait carrément enfermé l'élève
qui avait embêté William.
Dans une salle.
-Pour le protéger.
-Ce moment m'a vraiment
fait comprendre
qu'il y avait un problème
avec William,
qu'il était pas
comme les autres.
Je l'avais déjà remarqué,
mais là, j'en étais sûr.
Musique douce
-Au cours de mon enfance,
j'ai le souvenir
d'avoir énormément intériorisé
au quotidien.
Tout comme William,
mon esprit tourmenté
rebutait mes camarades,
me poussant à la faute.
Je ne trouvais pas le moyen
d'expulser sainement mes colères.
A l'école,
l'autorité était la règle.
Aucune possibilité
d'être écouté.
En tout cas,
c'est ce que je ressentais.
Chahut d'enfants
-J'essaie d'ignorer,
mais je suis assis
en face, maintenant.
-Comment vous êtes placés ?
-Chaque élève du dispositif
a un tuteur
qui est, en général,
un de ses professeurs.
Il y a une familiarité
qui se fait
entre le tuteur et l'élève
au fil de l'année.
-Je regarde
la dernière note
et je vois 6/10.
Je me dis "Bon, bah j'aurais pu
faire mieux", etc.
J'ai un peu pleuré,
à un moment.
-On a tous le droit
de pleurer,
mais essayez de prendre
de plus en plus sur vous
pour intégrer la crise.
Essayez d'écrire
comment vous avez réussi à gérer.
D'accord ?
-Là, il a l'occasion
d'exprimer tout ce qu'il ressent
par rapport à sa scolarité.
La parole est très libre.
Le rôle du tuteur,
c'est d'écouter l'élève.
-Hippolyte a sauté
deux classes,
donc c'est difficile
pour les anniversaires.
En fait, il a des amis
dans une première classe,
il en a d'autres
dans une autre classe,
et il en a encore d'autres
en 6e, donc...
-Son rôle aussi consiste
à jouer
le rôle d'intermédiaire
avec les professeurs
lors de malentendus,
même si la plupart
sont assez au fait
des problématiques de la précocité
dans le collège.
-Les adultes...
Surtout mon tuteur,
il me comprend.
Il y a pas
de sujet tabou.
Enfin, je peux lui parler
de tout, de tout.
-Ca va mieux,
par rapport à hier ?
-Bah ouais, hier soir en rentrant,
ça allait mieux.
Je pense que c'est
le truc d'espagnol
qui me prenait bien
la tête.
Voilà.
Je pense que c'était
surtout la fatigue,
en grande majorité,
mais sinon,
je sais pas trop.
-Félicitations, en tout cas.
Ton intuition s'est pas vérifiée.
Tu te souviens
de ce que tu m'as dit, hier ?
-Non.
-Que quand t'étais dans cet état,
il y avait de gros incidents...
-Ah oui...
Bah écoute,
j'ai pris sur moi.
Le professeur acquiesce.
-Donc comment t'as fait ça ?
-Bah...
Je me suis juste dit...
"Faut te calmer, William.
Faut pas faire de connerie."
-Moi, j'ai cru vraiment,
au bout d'un moment,
que t'allais commencer
à le chercher un peu, à le taquiner,
à te bagarrer...
-Je peux pas le voir en peinture.
En fait, je me reconnais en lui,
si tu vois ce que je veux dire.
Je sais ce qui se passe
dans sa tête pour qu'il fasse ça.
-Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
pour qu'il provoque ?
-L'attention des gens.
-C'est pour avoir de l'attention ?
-J'étais pareil !
Mais genre, trois ans de moins.
-Ah ouais ?
-T'imagines, mes profs ?
C'était...
-Tu veux dire avant le collège ?
-Ouais.
-T'étais pas un peu comme ça
quand t'es arrivé ?
-Oui, mais j'étais
encore pire avant.
Musique intrigante
...
J'avais pas vraiment d'amis
en élémentaire.
Il y avait souvent des...
Des bagarres
ou des disputes.
J'étais dans des histoires.
J'étais dans aucun groupe.
J'étais tout seul, dans mon coin.
-On en parlait avec les enseignants,
avec le directeur.
On ne savait pas
par où l'aborder.
-Ce que je trouve aussi
assez mystérieux, parfois,
mais très intéressant,
c'est d'essayer de comprendre
comment des élèves,
qui ont tout pour réussir
et se sentir bien à l'école,
rencontrent des difficultés
à certains moments
de leur scolarité.
Ca interroge l'école,
ça interroge les enseignants.
-Enfant, j'avais les difficultés
qu'ils ont eues :
difficulté à gérer l'échec,
à gérer la relation
avec les autres.
J'ai redoublé 3 fois.
Ca a été compliqué.
La vie à la maison
était pas facile non plus.
J'aurais pu être détecté
haut potentiel.
J'ai fait le test assez tardivement,
l'an dernier.
Il y avait pas tout ça.
-THP,
très haut potentiel.
Michaël rit.
Il dit "haut potentiel", mais non,
il est très haut potentiel.
-Je me suis rattrapé
avec mon métier.
En faisant
mon baptême de l'air,
j'ai compris que l'aviation,
c'était mon truc.
Les sujets qui m'intéressaient
étaient plus de niveau lycée
ou post-bac,
alors que j'étais au collège.
Le cours continue à avancer,
et vous, vous n'écoutez plus,
vous faites autre chose.
C'est difficile
d'être captivé par un interrupteur
et une ampoule,
quand on regarde le fonctionnement
d'une centrale nucléaire.
Il y a eu un moment où j'étais
vraiment au fond du trou.
Il y a un enseignant
qui m'a remis le pied à l'étrier.
Ca a tenu 2-3 ans et ça m'a permis
de reprendre confiance.
Du jour où j'ai eu ça...
William siffle.
Réacteur d'avion
-Parfois,
on a tendance à faire
tout de suite un lien de causalité
en disant :
"Il a ces difficultés-là,
parce qu'il est à haut potentiel."
Je trouve ça dangereux.
-C'est sûr que c'est
beaucoup plus consensuel
de dire à une famille :
"Monsieur, madame,
votre enfant est surdoué."
C'est beaucoup plus facile
de dire ça a des parents :
"La raison de tout ce malheur,
c'est une qualité."
Nous rencontrons
que des enfants en souffrance,
donc on a le sentiment...
Enfin, certains psys,
pas très rigoureux,
ont véhiculé cette association
entre intelligence élevée
et malheur, mais c'est injustifié.
-Il y a des sujets
qui vont gâcher leur potentialité
à cause de facteurs
qui n'ont rien à voir
avec l'intelligence.
Musique troublante
...
-Comme si c'était hier.
J'ai 5 ans.
Depuis l'arrière
de la voiture,
je perçois l'inquiétude de mon père
dans son regard.
...
Des pneus crissent.
Ses lunettes s'arrachent
de son visage.
Collision
Ca tourne. Je me cramponne.
...
Verrais-je la fin
de cette journée ?
...
Ma petite soeur
n'est pas avec nous.
Elle fait la sieste
à la maison.
A côté de moi, les bris de verre
transpercent son petit siège auto.
A partir de là,
rien ne sera plus comme avant.
...
L'insouciance de l'enfance
a laissé place
à une anxiété permanente.
...
Musique intrigante
-Uhaïna a su parler très tôt,
et quand elle a commencé à parler,
elle posait beaucoup de questions
autour de la mort,
des questions
autour de l'existence de la Terre,
la création du monde,
des choses assez mystiques.
Quand j'ai su qu'Uhaïna...
Enfin, quand le diagnostic
a été posé,
même si j'avais
de gros doutes,
sinon je l'aurais pas
fait tester,
je l'ai pas du tout pris
comme une bonne nouvelle.
J'ai perdu mon père
avant qu'Uhaïna soit née.
Musique triste
Elle était très affectée
de pas connaître son grand-père.
Un jour,
elle avait
3 ans et quelques,
Uhaïna a fait
une réflexion
autour de ça en disant
qu'elle l'avait pas connu.
Il pouvait pas exister
en elle,
puisqu'elle l'avait pas connu,
puisqu'elle n'existait pas.
Et puis d'un coup,
elle m'a regardée et elle m'a dit :
"En fait, si, j'existais déjà,
puisque avant de m'avoir,
"papa et toi,
vous m'avez imaginée."
Elle avait 3 ans.
En fait, je suis restée
un peu estomaquée
devant un truc pareil.
Je trouvais qu'elle avait raison
et je lui ai dit.
Elle existait déjà,
puisqu'elle existait
dans notre imaginaire.
En fait, je pense
que ça a été la réflexion
qui a un peu déclenché
le fait que je me suis dit
qu'il fallait faire
un bilan.
-Ils vont, par exemple,
se poser des questions métaphysiques
à un âge
où ils ne sont pas toujours prêts
à pouvoir faire face
à l'angoisse vertigineuse
de l'infini,
à des questions sur la mort
et après la mort,
des choses comme ça.
Quand vous vous posez ces questions
et que vous avez 7 ans,
alors qu'on se les pose plutôt
à l'adolescence, c'est pas évident.
-J'aimais pas l'école,
parce que je m'ennuyais un peu
en classe,
parce que c'était pas trop
des trucs
que j'avais
spécialement envie d'étudier.
Je me détestais
d'être précoce
et d'être comme ça.
En primaire, ils comprenaient pas
que je préférais
passer la majorité du temps
avec des livres
qu'avec des gens.
Au collège...
Enfin, les adultes...
Surtout mon tuteur,
il me comprend,
donc c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez nouveau.
-Tu as dit aussi hier....
-Tutorat tous les jours !
-Elle aurait aimé ça tous les jours
et pas qu'une fois par semaine !
C'est que ça fonctionne bien,
si t'en demandes plus.
Oui, oui.
-Bah oui, parce que j'ai...
A chaque fois,
je pourrais rester encore une heure,
car je lui ai pas tout dit.
-Souvent,
c'est des élèves
qui ont une personnalité
assez forte.
Même ceux qui sont réservés,
au fond,
ils ont souvent
une grande richesse intérieure,
une curiosité intellectuelle.
-S'ils ne rencontrent pas
un environnement
qui est à l'écoute
de ces particularités-là,
ça peut effectivement
être source
de souffrance, de décrochage,
de désintérêt, d'ennui...
Un enfant qui a des troubles
de l'attention,
on va essayer d'adapter les choses
pour que ça puisse aller.
Un enfant qui a une dyslexie,
on va aussi adapter les choses.
C'est un devoir de l'école
d'être à l'écoute
des besoins de chacun.
-A son jeune âge,
Léopold a déjà traversé
de lourdes épreuves.
A 3 ans,
ses parents se séparent.
Lorsque son père meurt,
il n'a que 6 ans.
Durant cette même année de CP,
on lui fait sauter une classe.
Très vite,
on lui diagnostique
un trouble du déficit
de l'attention, le TDAH.
Il est réorienté
vers une classe spécialisée,
une classe Ulis,
pour les élèves
en situation de handicap.
Traité avec de la Ritaline,
un médicament
qui régule l'hyperactivité,
Léopold régresse,
mais son haut potentiel
est identifié par un psychologue.
Sa mère apprend l'existence
du dispositif d'intégration
des élèves à haut potentiel
mis en place
au collège Georges Brassens.
-Je pense
que ça mérite d'être relu.
-"Poulette et le renard.
"Le renard s'incrusta
dans le congrès annuel
"du club des amis des poules,
"afin de croquer
quelques animaux à plumes."
J'étais avant
dans un collège
où ça se passait
plutôt mal...
C'était là où mon TDAH
s'était beaucoup développé, en fait.
Il s'était beaucoup développé.
Je faisais
beaucoup de bêtises...
Je faisais pas mon travail,
en fait.
Je pense que c'est parce que
je me sentais pas trop à ma place,
surtout quand ils m'ont mis en...
-En classe Ulis.
Tu te sentais pas
à ta place, en effet.
Il y a jamais eu de résultats...
de mauvais résultats.
Il y a juste eu
un arrêt du travail.
-Je regrette
qu'il n'y ait pas
d'observatoire
de la scientificité
des psychologues
qui s'expriment dans les médias
parce que ça aurait évité
à un grand nombre de professionnels
et de familles et d'enfants,
tout particulièrement,
d'être fourvoyés
dans des explorations
diagnostiques flottantes
et dans des diagnostics infructueux,
voire cruels,
pour le destin des enfants.
-Quand on a déménagé
dans le 19e arrondissement,
j'ai donc changé de collège,
et là, ça se passait beaucoup mieux.
J'ai pas été collé
une seule fois.
Je fais mon travail,
j'ai des bonnes notes.
-Quand il y a un décalage
entre la façon de penser de l'autre
et la sienne,
enfin un trop gros décalage,
et puis une vivacité
d'esprit,
le fait d'avoir
tout de suite la réponse,
un répondant qui fuse,
c'est assez impressionnant.
Il y a un côté aussi solitaire,
le fait de pas trop supporter
le bruit,
de ne pas avoir du mal
à communiquer avec les autres.
-C'est vrai que le bruit...
-Par exemple, Léopold,
il supporte pas
de manger à la cantine.
-Je fais pas des crises.
C'est juste que ça me dérange.
Je fais pas des crises.
-Non, tu pourrais,
mais c'est compliqué.
-Je pourrais faire des crises ?
-Non.
Tu pourrais manger
à la cantine.
Je lui fais
des paniers repas.
Mmh ?
Donc, il mange en salle A120
avec madame Le Maire.
-Comment tu sais ?
-Parce que je me rappelle.
Donc, en petit comité.
Voilà.
-Ca va, Léopold ?
-Très bien, et vous ?
-Ca va. Comment s'est passée
la semaine ?
-Elle s'est très bien passée.
Ce matin, j'ai fait
un contrôle d'anglais,
qui s'est très bien passé,
sur les métiers.
-Par rapport à ce que tu me disais
la dernière fois,
sur le fait
que tu étais un peu fatigué ?
-Je suis toujours un peu fatigué
parce que ce matin,
je me suis levé un peu tôt.
-Parce que moi, je trouve
que t'es un peu différent.
-Avec la Ritaline ?
-Oui.
-Ah ben, comment ?
-Comme je te disais
la dernière fois,
je te trouve plus vif,
tu réponds très vite,
t'es plus...
-Ah oui, avec la Ritaline,
j'étais toujours très fatigué.
Là, je le suis un peu moins,
mais encore un peu.
-Donc là, t'es plus vivant,
on va dire.
-Oui.
-Mais en classe,
sur la concentration,
t'arrives à rester sur une tâche
sans avoir à un moment besoin
de regarder ailleurs ou de...
Toi, ça va ? Il y a pas de souci ?
-Non, pas de souci.
-Non mais si tu sens vraiment
que c'est difficile,
il faut le dire.
-Non, c'est pas difficile.
-Les troubles de l'attention,
parfois, ça peut masquer
le haut potentiel
parce qu'ils arrivent pas
à tenir en place,
ils bougent beaucoup,
ils sont distraits.
Alors, à nouveau, on a tendance
un peu à les qualifier
de pas très malins.
Les enseignants les disqualifient.
Le testing est plus compliqué aussi.
On peut se tromper.
C'est important
que ce soit fait
par un professionnel compétent,
qui sait ce que c'est,
une dyslexie,
qui sait ce que c'est, un TDH,
qui sait ce que c'est,
un trouble du spectre
de l'autisme.
-Arthur, testé
en même temps que son frère,
est identifié haut potentiel.
On lui diagnostique aussi
une dyslexie,
que l'entourage
ne soupçonnait pas du tout.
-Certaines épreuves
du test haut potentiel,
j'étais incapable
mais vraiment incapable
de les faire.
On me donnait
une suite de nombres.
Je devais la dire
dans l'autre sens,
j'étais incapable
de le faire.
Incapable.
-Il a été diagnostiqué
dyslexique
fin CE1.
C'est-à-dire que
jusqu'avant la fin du CE1,
on avait l'impression
qu'Arthur lisait.
Ca se voyait pas.
Donc, effectivement,
le haut potentiel lui a permis
de masquer tout ça
jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus
de stratégie possible.
A un moment donné,
il faut savoir lire,
on peut pas faire sans.
-Par exemple,
quand on était petit,
on nous donnait
des histoires faciles,
"Le petit chaperon rouge",
trois lignes par page.
Je connaissais
l'histoire par coeur.
Donc, je décodais à peu près
difficilement
les deux premières lettres.
Avec le contexte,
je connaissais.
"Le grand méchant loup attrapa
le chaperon rouge
et sa grand-mère..."
-Ca va, c'est facile.
-Par contre,
quand on nous sort un texte
qui vient
de je ne sais où,
là, je...
-J'observe chez certains enfants
et chez certains adultes
un surinvestissement un peu défensif
de la pensée,
c'est-à-dire une propension
à utiliser l'intelligence,
la réflexion,
la maîtrise culturelle
d'information
comme une défense.
Ca peut protéger
de certaines effractions,
de certaines anxiétés, etc.
-Dans le développement
et la factorisation, si tu calcules
en deux étapes, c'est autorisé.
Pour un groupe
avec des rapidités
d'exécution des tâches
très variables,
quand un élève DIEHP
a saisi une notion,
il va avoir tendance à la saisir
dans son ensemble.
Ses mécanismes psychiques
vont commencer
à s'intéresser aux cas particuliers,
justement, à ces fameuses limites,
alors que nous, déjà,
on veut faire comprendre
au groupe classe
le cas général.
-2,5 centimètres ?
-Exactement.
Ce dont on se rend compte,
c'est qu'il y a
un problème assez général,
des problèmes d'énoncé,
c'est-à-dire que l'élève
est complètement en capacité,
voire a les connaissances
pour résoudre les problèmes,
mais est en difficulté
parce qu'il a mal lu l'énoncé,
mal compris l'énoncé,
ou il manque de confiance en lui.
-Je prends l'exemple de Léopold,
mais il est pas le seul
dans la classe,
d'aller plus loin que la question
et de pas répondre à la question.
Donc il a pas les points
parce que la question
est simple, bête et méchante.
-Il y a deux actions différentes.
Alors, d'abord...
-C'est des précipitations
cognitives.
Le fait d'investir
la pensée
avec autant d'appétit,
parce que dans la précipitation,
on court quand même plus vite
que les autres,
ça témoigne d'un appétit
pour la réflexion,
pour la pensée.
Donc, on n'est pas très étonné
que ces enfants se retrouvent
parfois à avoir un QI élevé
parce qu'ils aiment réfléchir,
ils aiment se remplir
d'informations.
-Ce qui peut être très intéressant,
justement,
c'est le fait de les solliciter
en tant qu'aide
aux autres camarades.
-Je suis convaincue que
ce ne sont pas les centres d'intérêt
qui font le liant entre enfants.
Je pense que ce qui écarte
les enfants les uns des autres,
c'est des dynamiques affectives,
des dynamiques relationnelles.
Un enfant qui est odieux
avec ses camarades,
qui est complètement désinhibé,
qui impose sa loi,
qui dit tout ce qu'il pense
et fait tout ce qu'il veut faire,
change les règles des jeux,
sera mis à l'écart par le groupe,
de toute façon.
Les enfants consultants,
QI élevé ou pas,
ils sont immatures.
-Les potentialités,
c'est quelque chose
qu'on va activer,
L'intelligence,
c'est un peu un outil
au service de l'apprentissage.
L'apprentissage n'est pas déterminé
que par notre intelligence,
il est déterminé par nos intérêts,
notre motivation,
le contexte social
dans lequel on est.
Des enfants sont parfois
en difficulté psychologique
parce que dans l'école,
ils sont harcelés.
Musique inquiétante
...
-Nous, on privilégie
systématiquement
l'arrivée en 6e
parce qu'on estime
qu'il y a des étapes
qui doivent être mises en place.
Quand les enfants arrivent
en 4e ou en 3e,
c'est très compliqué.
C'est des enfants
qui arrivent très fragilisés.
On a de la phobie scolaire,
on a des enfants
qui n'ont plus confiance en l'école,
qui sont cassés par le système.
Musique douce
...
-L'être humain n'est pas
très bon observateur,
n'est pas nécessairement
un bon juge.
On a beaucoup, beaucoup étudié
ces dernières années
en psychologie sociale
les biais de jugement.
Ne se baser
que sur son jugement intuitif
ne garantit pas du tout
de faire un bon jugement.
-En primaire, on me disait
que mon fils avait des problèmes
de mémoire, de concentration.
On a toujours évoqué des moins,
jamais des plus.
On s'est jamais demandé
si mon fils s'ennuyait en classe
alors que moi,
je l'ai déjà évoqué
avec des professeurs principaux :
"Peut-être qu'il s'ennuie."
Donc...
On n'a jamais été entendus.
Aux cours préparatoires,
15 jours après la rentrée,
elle avait déjà fait
des groupes.
Elle avait déjà fait
des groupes de niveaux :
les mauvais, les moyens, les bons.
Mon fils était avec les mauvais.
Musique mélancolique
Le tonnerre gronde.
...
-Mais ça a été ça,
le problème.
J'aurais dû arriver
sûrement un an avant
à Georges Brassens.
-Merci à tous d'être venus.
Adrien ?
-Ouais.
Du coup, j'ai trois élèves.
Alors, on va commencer
avec Ilias en 3e.
C'est un élève qui était
en échec scolaire l'année dernière,
qui n'allait plus
dans son collège
et il estimait
qu'il avait été un peu,
même carrément harcelé
par les adultes
de son ancien collège.
Le gros point positif,
c'est qu'il a renoué
la confiance
avec l'institution
et les adultes.
Ca, c'est quand même
un gros point pour Brassens.
Le revers de la médaille, c'est
qu'il se sent tellement à l'aise
qu'il décroche.
On lui demande de participer,
il participe pas.
C'est un peu la cata
avec les orientations.
Ca se passe bien
en techno, en sport et en art,
mais voilà, c'est tout.
Du coup, on se retrouve...
Ouais, là, on se retrouve...
-Un peu dans une impasse, là.
-Complètement.
C'est le mot que je cherchais.
-Déjà, juste avoir
quelqu'un avec qui
tu peux parler, donc Adrien,
ça change beaucoup
de mon ancien établissement,
parce que tu pouvais
parler à personne.
C'est vrai
qu'en début d'année
et en milieu d'année,
c'était pas...
Les résultats
étaient pas fameux,
mais je me suis beaucoup amélioré
au niveau des notes
vers la fin d'année.
C'est ça qui m'a permis
de pouvoir être accepté
en seconde générale.
-Trop bien.
-Ils s'occupent
beaucoup plus de toi.
Il hésite.
Ils me prêtaient plus attention.
Juste de dire que j'avais fait
un bon boulot,
que le travail était bien,
que je m'étais investi,
ça fait du bien
d'entendre ça, quoi.
-Il y a certains enseignants aussi
qui n'ont pas forcément
les connaissances également
pour voir derrière peut-être
un élève qui a
des problèmes de comportement
ou des résultats décevants
un élève à haut potentiel.
-L'histoire personnelle d'Ilias
m'évoque ma propre histoire.
Il n'est pas simple,
quand un élève
ne s'épanouit pas à l'école,
de faire entendre ses ambitions
à propos de son avenir.
Des décisions importantes
peuvent être prises
à un âge précoce.
Hélas, certains raccourcis
empruntés ces dernières années
amènent certains parents
à attribuer
le mal-être de leurs enfants
à leurs grandes capacités
intellectuelles.
-Un jour, j'ai rencontré
une jeune fille
qui était vraiment brillantissime.
Elle ne pouvait pas s'arrêter
de lire et de se renseigner
et elle était décrochée
des intérêts des autres.
Elle était aussi assez agressive
avec les autres,
elle était fâchée, etc.
J'ai rencontré sa maîtresse,
le directeur
de son école.
On a fait des réunions
et j'ai dit :
"Il faut lui faire sauter
"une classe,
elle s'ennuie trop."
Elle est décrochée
des affinités des autres.
C'était au début de ma carrière.
J'ai cédé à cette facilité,
cette illusion
que la souffrance
de cette enfant
pouvait être "guérie"
par un aménagement
du cadre scolaire.
Le résultat,
c'est que l'année d'après,
elle est devenue boulimique,
c'est-à-dire
que l'avidité qui avait diffusé
dans la pensée
avait été rassasiée,
et donc,
elle s'était déplacée ailleurs.
Il y avait une séparation
entre les parents
qui était très douloureuse,
une mère qui allait mal.
Elle se défendait de lui ressembler
en intellectualisant.
Lui faire sauter des classes
n'aurait rien résolu.
Le noyau de la souffrance
de cette enfant
était bien
dans son vivier familial.
Donc, l'idée d'être trop intelligent
pour être heureux
est un slogan marketing malhonnête.
Musique électro-pop
-Lorsque j'allais à l'école,
j'y allais
non pas comme un touriste
- j'étais pas au Club Med -,
mais comme un passant.
Je me verse moi-même le thé,
bien au milieu du bol.
Le sucre doit être vertical !
Sinon, c'est le bazar.
Ensuite, je range tout,
les mômes, les gosses.
C'est la même chose.
Je range la voiture
et j'astique le zèbre.
J'ai toujours eu des zèbres.
Les rayures sont parallèles.
Sous prétexte
que l'on est haut potentiel,
il y a une supériorité
intellectuelle qui fait
qu'on surpasserait tout le monde,
qu'on aurait des notes explosives,
c'est complètement chimérique,
c'est pas vrai.
Applaudissements
Je me crois digne de ta flamme
Et de porter ton nom
Car pour m'avoir choisie pour femme
Faut vraiment que tu sois
-CON
-Je ne pourrai jamais cracher
sur le système de l'éducation,
même s'il est parfaitement imparfait
à bien des égards.
Je pense que tu t'accorderas
sur ce point-là avec moi.
Le terme d'assiduité,
je ne peux pas l'associer à l'école,
mais à ce que je faisais
extrascolairement.
Mes résultats étaient inégaux,
hautement inégaux.
En classe de 4e,
c'était vraiment pas la joie.
J'étais...
Je n'étais pas épanoui,
c'est une évidence,
avec mes camarades,
qui, franchement,
ne me confortaient pas dans l'idée
que j'avais ma place
dans cette classe.
Donc, madame de Michèle
a décidé
en tant que principale,
de me faire sauter une classe.
Alors, c'était une décision...
Voilà... qui a été un poids.
Ca a fait remue-ménage.
Je vous laisse imaginer.
Mais ça c'est fait.
Je n'ai pas sauté
une classe pour le plaisir.
Elle m'a dit :
"Je suis convaincue
"que plus vite vous sortirez
du système scolaire,
"plus vite vous serez épanouis".
Mais ça, c'était un cadeau...
remarquable.
Il faut saluer les êtres exquis
qu'on rencontre comme ça.
Musique douce
...
-"La couleur du verre brisé
se reflète sur ta main.
"Ton sourire à l'air d'hurler
que tu m'appartiens.
"Tu es mien, je suis tiens.
Ton odeur me rend ivre de bonheur.
"Tout à coup, je ne la sens plus.
Je veux respirer. Où es-tu ?
...
"Je hurle mon impuissance
face à la mort.
"Devant elle, je ne suis rien,
"mais j'aimerais être tout,
"t'arracher de ses bras
et te glisser dans les miens.
"Au nom des dieux
auxquels je ne crois pas,
"au nom de tout, au nom de rien :
s'il te plaît, reviens.
"Je veux ton souffle,
ta voix et ton odeur.
"Je veux respirer. Où es-tu ?
"Te partager avec la mort
ne me convient pas."
...
En général,
quand j'écris longtemps,
c'est plutôt du fantastique.
Après...
Il y a des thématiques
qui se rejoignent.
Il y a souvent des histoires,
quand j'écris,
autour de la mort, surtout.
Quand je suis
dans des moods négatifs
et que j'écris des trucs,
après, comme c'est sorti de moi,
ça va un peu mieux.
Au début, quand j'ai écrit,
c'était parce que je faisais
beaucoup de cauchemars.
Du coup, j'ai commencé à écrire
des histoires sur les thèmes
qui me préoccupaient.
Au début, je réfléchissais
pas forcément pour en faire
mon métier, mais...
Depuis un certain temps, je me dis
que ça pourrait être sympa.
Quand j'étais petite,
moi, j'aurais bien aimé
que quelqu'un vienne parler
avec moi de littérature
dans la cour
ou ce genre de choses,
et c'était pas trop leur truc.
Etre plus mature
intellectuellement parlant
que la majorité
des enfants de mon âge,
sur certains trucs,
ça peut être bien, mais...
ça peut être pas ouf
par rapport aux centres d'intérêt.
Avec mes amis, on rigole bien,
donc ça, c'est chouette.
Les trucs engagés, aussi.
On parle pas mal de politique.
Dans le collège,
il n'y a pas trop de racisme,
mais il y a beaucoup,
beaucoup d'homophobie.
Tu marches dans les couloirs
et on te dit :
"Espèce de gros
pédé".
Ca devient une insulte
entre potes :
"Si tu me touches, ça veut dire
que tu es gay. Me touche pas."
Il y a du sexisme, aussi,
principalement.
En fait, j'ai quand même
la chance d'être dans un collège,
globalement,
avec des idées politiques
pas trop nulles, mais...
Ca empêche pas qu'il y ait
des gens complètement stupides.
Musique douce
...
-William,
c'est l'exemple même
de la réussite de tout
un établissement scolaire.
Il a fait une 6e très compliquée.
Conseil de discipline
en 5e, il a failli
être exclu du collège.
4e, déjà un grand changement.
Et cette année, William,
on voit vraiment l'évolution.
...
-Je préférais les jeux de logique,
de stratégie, de réflexion,
que d'aller dans la cour,
courir ou faire du sport.
A l'époque,
j'aimais pas trop le sport :
souvent, il faut être plusieurs.
Comme j'avais pas d'amis,
je pouvais pas jouer donc
je préférais rester dans la classe.
...
-Ma dyslexie
masque un petit peu
mon haut potentiel.
J'ai certains résultats qui sont
super hauts.
J'en ai d'autres qui sont aussi
super bas.
Musique énigmatique
...
-Au cours des expériences
de la vie,
j'ai réalisé que l'exploitation
du potentiel de chacun
dépend aussi
des différentes rencontres
que l'on peut faire.
Faut-il encore
qu'il y ait un dialogue
entre adultes et enfants.
Pour moi, le manque d'écoute
que je ressentais
m'a parfois joué des tours.
L'école est l'essentiel
du quotidien d'un enfant.
Y arriver le matin avec la boule
au ventre est intolérable.
-Tout le monde connaît
le parcours d'Albert Camus
qui vient d'un milieu
extrêmement pauvre en Algérie,
et qui a un instituteur,
qui était monsieur Germain,
qui repère quand même
ce petit garçon
qui est quand même doué.
C'est très touchant,
le discours de Camus
quand il a été reçu
pour son prix Nobel
où il a rendu hommage
à son instituteur,
parce qu'en effet,
sans son instituteur,
il n'aurait sans doute pas été
où il était à ce moment-là.
-"Cher monsieur Germain,
j'ai laissé s'éteindre un peu
"le bruit qui m'a entouré
ces jours-ci
"avant de venir vous parler
un peu de tout mon coeur.
"On vient de me faire
un bien trop grand honneur
"que je n'ai ni recherché
ni sollicité.
"Quand j'ai appris la nouvelle,
"ma première pensée après ma mère
a été pour vous.
"Sans vous,
sans cette main affectueuse
"que vous avez tendue
au petit enfant pauvre que j'étais,
"sans votre enseignement
et votre exemple,
"rien de tout cela
ne serait arrivé."
-"Mon cher petit,
j'ai l'impression que ceux
"qui essayent de percer
ta personnalité
"n'y arrivent pas tout à fait.
"Tu as toujours montré
une pudeur instinctive
"à déceler ta nature,
tes sentiments.
"Tu y arrives d'autant mieux
que tu es simple,
"direct et bon,
par-dessus le marché.
"Ces impressions,
tu les as données en classe.
"Je crois donc bien connaître
"le gentil petit bonhomme
que tu étais.
"Et l'enfant, bien souvent, contient
en germe l'homme qu'il deviendra."
...
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
...